le premier tour de l'élection
législative partielle se tiendra le
dimanche 2 octobre dans la 2e
circonscription des yvelines alors
pourquoi faut-il organiser un nouveau
scrutin dans cette circonscription
uniquement petit rappel des faits
[Musique]
le 4 juillet dernier jean noël barrot
alors député de la 2e circonscription
des yvelines est nommé ministre délégué
en charge de la transition numérique et
des télécommunications un mois plus tard
le 4 août anne crignon sa suppléante
leur en place à l'assemblée nationale
elle devient donc député de la 2e
circonscription des yvelines mais
quelques jours plus tard elle décide de
démissionner de l'assemblée nationale la
raison un recours a été déposé devant le
conseil constitutionnel
il se trouve que à grignon et la
remplaçante du sénateur la république en
marge des yvelines martin lévriers elle
ne pouvait donc pas se présenter en tant
que suppléante de jean noël barrot à
l'assemblée nationale un fondement à
partir de l'article l au 134 du code
électoral un député un sénateur ou le
remplaçant d'un membre d'une assemblée
parlementaire ne peut être remplaçant
qu'un candidat à l'assemblée nationale
la démission d'un crillon anticiper donc
ce recours qui allait des chances
d'aboutir les électeurs de la 2e
circonscription sont donc appelés aux
urnes le dimanche 2 octobre avec la
possibilité d'un second tour le 9
octobre et pour rappel en juin dernier
lors des élections législatives jean
noël barrot avait obtenu près de 35% des
voix et au second tour il avait
largement devancé la candidate de la
nuque ps maïté qu'arrive b doit ni avec
plus de 64% des voix